NCIS guest star Annie woren died from
cancer in January 2023 at the age of
just 45 though she was better known for
her roles on the show's 24 The Vampire
Diaries in Bosch as well as playing Tess
in the acclaimed video game The Last of
Us woring appeared as Deputy da Gail
Walsh in the NCIS season 8 episode false
witness deadline reported that woring
was diagnosed with cancer in 2020 but
she didn't let that keep her from the
career she loved and she continued
working as long as she was able in 2022
she played the Borg Queen in season 2 of
Star Trek Bard and she continued with
her recurring role as Rosalyn Dyer on
the rookie until 2022 her Bard role
brought her career full circle her
earliest screen credit was on Star Trek
Enterprise in 2002 actor Abigail Spencer
who worked with woring on the show
Timeless shared a heartfelt tribute to
woring on Instagram calling her the best
scene partner Spencer added that woring
was the backbone and the ringer on many
shows she graced